Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it is a time for a special edition of the Monday morning
podcast.
You and all,
every once in a while,
um,
old freckles here goes out and gets himself a guest and today is no different,
which is why we have a special podcast for this weekend.
I can't think of a,
this is probably the biggest,
it's gotta be the biggest guest.
I've had an absolute legend.
And usually when people say this shit,
they can't,
you know,
people you can't follow it.
But believe it or not,
I have a from Aerosmith,
legendary lead guitars.
Joe Perry on the Monday morning podcast.
How are you buddy?
I'm really good.
Thanks.
Uh,
I don't know about the biggest part.
I mean,
most people say you look bigger.
I mean you'll look smaller in person,
but uh,
don't you hate that it don't matter.
I mean,
you know,
it's all,
it's all about the camera,
England and all that stuff.
But uh,
thanks.
I appreciate that.
Then intro and do you get that a lot?
Be here today?
Oh,
sorry.
Do you get that a lot?
People say that to me,
like,
I don't know why they think I was tall.
I'm average height,
I'm just under five,
10.
And then they always come walking up.
They're like,
oh,
I thought you'd be a lot bigger.
It's just,
it's the way that the camera,
because usually a camera,
again,
technically,
I mean the carers kind of down at eye level because they want to get you
straight on and,
or sometimes they'll shoot you from a little below.
So it's really hard to tell,
um,
to get any kind of perspective,
you know what I mean?
Unless you know how tall the person is,
you're standing next to that kind of thing.
Um,
I get it with you.
It's like you're playing like,
you know,
the La Coliseum and you're on like a 40 foot stage.
I mean,
I'm standing in some chuckle hut.
It's just like maybe six inches taller than I am when I'm not on stage.
So,
um,
I don't know.
That's always like,
sometimes I just think people just say shit to say shit and like,
do you,
how do you deal with like,
you know,
what like amazes me about before it,
boy,
before we get going here,
uh,
the reason why Joe Perry is here,
he's got a new unbelievable book,
uh,
Joe Barry Gi Joe Perry,
my life in and out of Aerosmith.
Uh,
that's available now in a form of,
um,
I'm not mistaken and already went number one,
correct?
Well,
I think it,
it was numbered.
It was an,
it's in the top 10,
uh,
was at the top 10,
New York Times bestseller list.
Uh,
it was in the top 10 for two weeks in.
This is why your career has lasted for so long because you're this honest,
most people would have just been like,
yeah,
man.
Yeah,
one all over the place.
But it's like anybody that,
uh,
you know,
sees it.
But the thing is,
it's all they say is top,
top seller and they print out on the top.
And that's kind of like the stamp that says that at least more than one person
has read it.
And,
uh,
the other thing is that I'm not here just because of the book.
I'm here because you're,
you're a bud from way back.
And I've been looking forward to doing a podcast with you anyway.
Awesome.
For a while.
So it's a,
yeah,
it gives me a chance to Yak about the book,
but I also get a chance to have some laughs for change.
She had a deal and I promise I'm going to try to steer away from the usual,
you know,
so what Steven,
like what's a,
how do you pick out your leather pants or whatever all,
I might ask you that one because I don't think asked me anything
and,
and I guarantee the,
the,
uh,
answers will be totally different than they've been from,
from before because a lot of it,
it's not so much the questions,
it's how they're asked and who's asking them.
Oh,
okay.
All right.
And I like that.
Well,
let me,
here's one for you is what blows my mind nowadays with the whole Twitter thing.
And Facebook and the whole interactive thing was back in the day.
Um,
there was no way for me to ever write you something that you would ever see,
I Guess Fan mail or something like that.
Just the level of like interaction that people can have.
In fact,
like when I,
when I bought your first albums,
it was like,
uh,
maybe 80,
81 or something like that.
So this was just before MTV,
right.
I didn't even know who was who because I turn over the album.
Sure.
Well I guess I got greatest sets first and they didn't have a picture of you
guys put on when I got like toys in the attic or something,
I remember I turned it over and I was trying to figure out which ones Steve,
which ones,
Joe,
you know,
who's Tommy and all that type of stuff.
Um,
what,
how have you felt like having lived the old way before,
like pre,
even like pre MTV,
but people didn't,
you know,
for them,
let's see what hardcore fans,
they had no idea what you look like.
Seeing you be a little more anonymous if you walked down the street to like this
whole thing now where people can be like,
uh,
no,
he's poke asshole.
Why did you pick this picture?
You know,
just sitting there eating toast and you're fucking kitchen and how doesn't that
doesn't annoy the shit.
I hate the fucking heckles when I'm at home.
Well,
it's interesting because you got one thing is you got to keep in mind that it's
a very small percentage of the people that are out there.
So,
you know,
a lot of times you can get sucked into the whole Twitter thing or Facebook or
all that,
all the different different outlets that they are.
And you can go,
God,
I can't believe that people think that or,
or how could they say that?
And it's like,
you got to remember that it's like maybe one of 1% that are actually like,
you know,
looking at it.
But,
uh,
well how long did the great scheme of things,
you know,
but it's Kinda like,
uh,
it's a good thing and a bad thing.
It gives people a voice and it's kind of like the look we've said before,
the,
uh,
it's like the town square and you're hanging out at the town squared.
Anybody can say what they want.
Some people want us to end it on a soap box so they can be heard.
And very often they get carried away in a white,
uh,
in a white
jacket.
But,
uh,
um,
so for you to get to the zen place,
cause it's something that I kind of bad like most times of like,
ah,
whatever,
you know,
whatever the last eight one good,
what are they all going to be good?
But like,
just every once in a while somebody just writes something so mean that I get
like an urge to like,
I just wish there was an app where you could find out where they lived and just
drive over and,
uh,
you know,
it's funny.
I'd drive over and then lose a fight to them.
But you know,
in my fantasy I went,
yeah,
well,
uh,
sometimes you have to do that to let off some steam,
but,
uh,
not actually do it,
but just kind of go through the middle process.
But the point is,
is that,
uh,
you read some of that stuff.
It could be so being spirited because they know that they're anonymous and it's
like,
could have been drag,
but,
uh,
I don't know.
Lately it's been,
uh,
pretty positive.
Okay.
That's cool.
It kind of ebbed and,
uh,
you know,
you've just kind of pay attention to the different woods every,
some people will listen to,
to like one particular thing or they'll kind of drop into at different phases
and things like that.
So I dunno,
it's just,
just another outlet.
Uh,
but,
uh,
but sometimes we do use it for a input where we talking about a subtlest the
road,
well,
we're thinking about it.
What should we put in there?
It's sometimes somebody will will tweet a song,
we'll go,
I think we remember how to play that one.
We'll throw it in.
Can I,
can I put out a request course one that I've always wanted to see play live.
It's off your first album.
Uh,
moving out.
Well let me write that down.
We do play once in a while.
I played it,
I think the second,
the last show of the tour and we went right into walking the dog.
So it was kind of like,
I think your first album is so underrated cause that if I remember correctly,
you basically,
uh,
you guys,
even after you sold that album,
you hadn't gone national yet and it was Kinda like,
um,
you kind of got like New Hampshire,
Vermont,
Maine,
Massachusetts or New England and maybe Justin to Connecticut and New York.
Um,
exactly.
And it was just,
it was really like a,
it was an uphill fight,
ma.
You know,
I mean it was,
uh,
you know,
people sick,
looking from the outside,
you know,
they're looking at the,
at the trade magazines that all of a sudden there's this band on the,
on the charts and it seems like there overnight.
But you know,
you forget.
I mean,
it goes,
it's been,
it's been the same ever since the Beatles.
I mean the Beatles spit years and years of those clubs in Hamburg,
sleeping in the bathroom,
working hard,
busting their ass.
And the same thing with,
with us.
I mean,
we worked the clubs and it kind of spread out.
It would,
you know,
we'd go through through,
uh,
Ohio and played,
you know,
all,
all the tells in Ohio and make it our way to Detroit.
And Detroit,
of course,
their favorite beard was j Geils.
So they were willing to give another band from Boston illicit and we give us a
second chance,
you know.
And,
uh,
when we went out there,
they,
they really,
uh,
took us to heart.
And then,
uh,
I've coming back to Boston,
the,
uh,
the first album,
was,
uh,
had,
had come and kind of gone,
but,
uh,
the record company gave us another chance and we did the second record that they
were rereleased streamline and,
uh,
it started to get played on the radio that was back with Djs,
could actually play what they wanted.
You know,
you could actually go up there and talked to them,
play them something,
but if it was any good they would play it.
You know,
it was pretty cool.
That's amazing.
You know what,
I was just back,
uh,
back east doing Dennis and Cam's a comics come home,
you know,
and believe it or not,
it was the 20th,
the 20th anniversary of that show.
And I remember times I did it,
you came out and played with the band,
which was awesome.
And um,
I'd say one thing that strikes me is every time I go back to Boston,
because I moved away in [inaudible] 95,
it becomes less and less like what I left and I'm going to be,
oh,
I'm going to get a greasy slice of pizza here.
And then it's gone.
And I'm just,
I'm finding it,
all these areas that used to be scary are getting like nicer and nicer.
And I remember you,
what always kills me was when they talk about when you guys were struggling,
they were like,
yeah,
we were all struggling.
We were all living in this beat up apartment on Commonwealth Avenue,
which is like Park Avenue now,
uh,
in,
in downtown Boston.
And I was wondering,
do you,
do you miss like when you go back,
go through Boston?
I don't know how often you get to go back there.
Do you,
um,
do you like the direction it went with the whole big dig and well turn in
Southie into like a bunch of condos and crap?
Certainly the big dig was,
uh,
was it event in everyone's life who lives in Boston?
But uh,
I mean it was,
there's no doubt it will just make one fucking lane.
They turned everything.
They was like,
it was a complete waste of time.
Oh.
And the other than aesthetically I'm fucking,
you know,
I was driving to the airport is I went to the airport,
I tried to take the Ted Williams title,
so I get off.
I have a 7:00 AM flights,
like quarter to five in the morning.
And so I get off the Ted Williams,
um,
exit and then it get to the fork in the road.
We make a left to do it and there's all these fucking cones set up.
So then I have to go by that.
And the Callahan tunnel flipping the fuck out,
curse in Boston,
up and down for the,
the,
the fucking state work on meathead.
And I don't even think that they did it by accident.
I literally think that they do it on purpose and then you fucking go through all
of the bullshit.
And once again,
it's one lane to get to the airport.
So it was like,
what was the purpose of all of that?
You know,
it's like go figure.
I mean there's,
there's,
it's all about progress under the name of progress.
I mean,
that's what this whole country's built on in growth and all that.
And I mean,
I think that things have to change there.
I don't want to add or want to get into that right now,
but,
but the bottom line is you're going to run for office.
So I just,
I haven't been home that much or been out here,
you know,
from the time we were working on the,
uh,
the,
the last Aerosmith record and then going on the road
and there's a couple of back and finish the record and they'd go down the road
again.
And then working on the book all through that.
We've been spending all my time here and,
uh,
no,
you sound like you caught a cold a little bit,
Andy.
Well,
the allergies here,
it's like,
it's really wet.
You know,
it's back here.
They've got,
he's got,
uh,
it's beautiful.
I mean he's got like fountains everywhere and uh,
it's just beautiful.
But,
um,
but the allergies Getcha and I was just reading an article in one of the,
like the Huffington posts and one of those,
one of those things and they were saying how that,
that people's,
uh,
people's allergies are not allergies but there,
their whole nasal thing was,
was like starting to like react to the,
a lot of the differences because they travel so much and,
and there are so many different things that affect people and so they're there.
They're no,
you're wondering why your nose is Jeffords.
It's why.
Because if your nose is working overtime,
it's got nothing to do with anything from south of the border,
you know,
or anything like that.
It's just strictly your,
your body reacting to,
uh,
to the,
to the different stuff in the year.
Whether its pollen,
I mean I know in Massachusetts does that time of the year where all the pine
pollen comes down and covers your car green and all that,
get sick then to ah,
I'll get like,
it's terrible.
It's kind of dragging nuts.
It's terrible.
It's like a,
how do you handle that?
If you have like a show,
if you're doing a Joe Perry thing,
Joe Perry project where you have to sing,
well,
a little bit of that spray,
you know,
that,
uh,
you know that you get at the drugstore and it works as long as you don't use too
much of it,
you know,
but it works and it's uh,
and uh,
then you get through it.
That's shit never works for me.
Somebody gave me that the other damn doing a cartoon.
Um,
oh,
we got to get ya.
Uh,
like we have music and stuff in between your projects.
Yeah,
we're kind of doing this thing,
it takes place in like the 70s.
I can't give too much of a way.
It's not coming out for like another year.
But,
uh,
you know,
we're,
we're doing some stuff of period stuff from the 70s.
I can remember when plant and paid used to do that call and response thing on
the guitar and he'd be,
like I said,
we kind of got some people listening to music like that.
And,
um,
I,
as I was driving over here today,
I was like,
Jesus Christ,
you know,
I mean,
I should've got yin on the fucking thing.
We're having somebody,
yeah.
Try to put together like a song for us or whatever,
but,
uh,
I love to have you come in,
maybe even do a voice or something like that.
That's one of the good things about,
uh,
but all this technology is,
you don't have to be in the same room at the same time.
You know?
I mean,
certainly there's a advantage to that,
but you know,
if,
if you can't be there physically,
you can certainly send the files and you can work on it and talk on the phone.
I mean,
I just stood,
uh,
um,
it over an overdub one would a Johnny Winters songs,
uh,
God rest his soul.
Uh,
and uh,
you know,
he called me up and said,
do you want to play the record?
You had great.
And,
uh,
they sent me the files,
I played on it.
And,
uh,
right.
Yeah.
Well here there's a studio writing store.
So,
uh,
we wanted him,
as you noticed,
I'm not too good with technology.
I got to tell my listeners the embarrassing beginning to my podcast.
I was in a rush to get over here,
freaking out.
Joe Perry from Aerosmith and I show up.
I got two microphones,
I've got everything,
but I only have one mic cord and Rockstar Joe Perry goes,
I'll go next door and get one.
Like he's getting out.
Like he has all cool neighbors.
So like he's like,
I'd go over and get a cup of sugar.
He goes over and gets up microphone cord
and Teresa Hagar roles with kind of musical people,
but also that we stay at the hotel,
the sunset marquee,
I don't know where you stand,
but they have a studio downstairs and that's the only hotel I know of in the
world where you can call room service and get a microphone at two in the
morning.
Is that right?
If you're like a,
I mean,
I've done a lot of,
uh,
of writing.
In fact,
there's a picture of me,
uh,
in,
in the,
in the room,
uh,
working on one of the songs for the record.
And,
uh,
you know,
and we just set up with the,
with the computer and the,
some,
some outboard gear,
some microphones.
And,
uh,
let me sit in there and,
and I actually wrote the song there and some of the tracks actually made it on
the record,
but,
you know,
we're just sitting in the living room,
and it's,
uh,
and I needed a mic cord and I called down.
They had it there.
And
do you find that that new technology makes you a more creative or is it like,
you know,
sometimes there's people out here,
whether even if they like,
right,
they're sitting there going like,
well,
I got to at least have an office where I go to sit down and write because if I
don't,
I'm sitting here,
the TV's here,
the kitchen's here.
I'm not going to create,
defined,
uh,
the new technology where wherever you go,
there's a studio makes you procrastinate more,
or do you work Mark Moore?
Definitely a lot more.
Uh,
a lot,
it takes a lot more,
uh,
get up and go to,
to do it because there are so many more distractions is there's no doubt about
it.
Everything from,
you know,
a thousand channels on TV to,
to whatever you're into.
I mean,
football 24 hours a day,
whatever,
there's so many things that,
you know,
it's an advantage because you can,
you can choose.
But on the other head it's like,
uh,
to be able to record it in your own house can be like the worst thing.
And the best thing,
I mean,
you can always say,
well,
I can put it off till tomorrow because you don't,
you know,
you haven't booked time in a studio where they're going to charge you $1,500 a
day,
whereas you've already put a deposit down on a studio and so you have to go.
So there's kind of like a,
there's that end of it.
And then there's also,
but it really has to from,
from inside and you have to really want to do it.
And,
uh,
I mean,
you know,
you're,
I mean,
you're a creative guy.
You see things in a different way that us,
you see,
you see the humor and stuff,
uh,
and you know,
stuff that we would never occur the rest of us.
But that's why you make us laugh.
And the thing is,
it's,
that's,
that's an art.
And
let me ask you this.
You said that that sunset marquee is the only hotel that you know that you can
order a microphone.
Uh,
what's the craziest thing you ever ordered?
Room service.
You're on the road,
you're in the middle of nowhere.
It wasn't so much the craziest thing.
It was the quantity.
Are we talking grams here?
What,
what did you order well enough for say 30 people?
Uh,
and what is it,
dawn,
dawn and yard,
uh,
by the case,
I was,
I could rub a stay at,
at the,
uh,
Beverly Hills hotel in the 70s,
and it was kind of like the,
uh,
party central,
cause they have bungalows out,
back,
you know,
like
everything can be cured as far as STDs go and all that.
I mean,
do you have a missed,
like I look at some of the 70s,
right?
And I just really wish,
I mean of course it's all been romanticized in books and movies and all that
shit,
but do you like aside,
everybody likes being younger.
Do you miss those days?
Like thinking about like just the how a lot freer and crazy you could be without
worrying about somebody with a cell phone camera.
I'm talking about single Joe Perry.
I got this drinking and drugging thing under control.
Like you just,
you just having a good time.
You playing with your band,
you're selling records and all that is a part of you that you have or just you
ever like when you're driving down sunset and just looking at spots going like,
dude I fucking bought a kilo of coke there and had one of the best hot dogs I
ever had in my life hanging with John Bonham or something.
Do you like,
do have memories like that still come?
Yeah,
I mean
no doubt.
I mean especially here in Manila and there are a couple of places that are
still,
you know,
the same buildings,
so have have changed the names.
But I mean this is a whiskey or Gogo and there's book soup which has been there
forever,
which is the greatest book.
Stores go next,
uh,
city lights up in Frisco and there's what Paris,
it's really good but,
but you know,
there,
there are these certain places that are still there and you know,
the rainbow and,
and the Roxy and uh,
some of the people you remember seeing in the rent just because fans are like,
like nerds.
It's like you just want to go to the same place that they stood in.
Chances are if,
if there,
if,
if they were playing in town,
uh,
you could almost guaranteed to be to see whoever was playing.
And then the rest of the time,
you know,
a lot of people would just,
if they were the middle of,
of a tour,
they had a couple of days off,
they would definitely come to la to hang out.
Cause it was such a great scene here,
you know,
back then and,
uh,
you could literally like rodents,
heady buddy.
What's the craziest thing you ever saw go down at like the rainbow room or the
whiskey or whatever?
Like the most,
I only hung out there a few times,
uh,
because you don't have to name any of them trying to get you in trouble.
But,
uh,
I just,
it was just a couple of times I've been there,
you know,
it'd be actually probably a lot more than I remember,
but,
uh,
yeah,
it's probably a lot more than than I,
than I would forget.
And you're the central person in the story.
You just don't remember the story.
What's Joe Perry.
But,
uh,
you know,
it was basically a kind of a meeting place for everybody.
They would come down from the hills,
you know,
run into whoever and then the tables would empty out and as people would take
off,
it was that kind of a place.
But,
uh,
I haven't been up there since,
Jesus in forever,
so,
uh,
well I can guarantee to you,
I don't think they've changed anything when you walk in that all of the covers
on the seat and everything just looked like they'd been there since the
beginning of time.
I would bet.
Uh,
and the whiskey is pretty much the same as I remember.
We played there our first time here in La and then we played there not too long
ago and it was pretty much the same,
was a great vibe.
You know,
it was kind of like,
uh,
the paradise,
I don't even know if they changed the paradise at all.
And Boston.
Yeah.
Do it.
The paradise has been gone for I think almost 20 years.
I guess it changed,
but uh,
it's probably like clubs still or is it a real,
you want to be one of those fucking Panera bread.
Yeah.
Things and you just thinking.
Yeah,
you too.
And the police started here or there for some of their first gigs,
I guess seen United States.
We're here.
You know,
I just realized as I'm sitting in here,
you probably,
and I can't imagine him,
I think the amount of times you've sat in a room,
whether it was just a suit of armor over in the corner.
Yeah.
Like some Scooby Doo shit seems like some real like rock star stuff.
Like you've got to have,
you just got to have a suit of armor.
Narya right.
That helps you be creative process.
It came with the place.
Oh,
it did it out.
Odd
me enough.
I did have one in my house in La in the 70s I had,
I had a suit of armor at the door.
And uh,
where do you,
where do you buy them?
Well,
you have to buy a castle while it's not a real one,
obviously I read,
it's not like,
uh,
like,
I mean you can tell it's just,
it's like a mock up of one,
but it still looks really cool.
And uh,
how do you know it's not real?
Because there's no,
because marks on,
if you look at it where the screws hold it,
hold it together,
they could have like didn't cut off the edge.
So if you were to put it on,
you'd kind of look like a,
you just got attacked by about,
uh,
about a hundred.
Uh,
mosquitoes are wasps or whatever because all those little,
those nails would be sticking in you.
Like if you took the helmet off,
could see like,
like the rivet sticking out.
So it's really been made to,
Oh,
I just looked at it,
but I didn't see any scuff marks on it.
I just figured that was like the king son now who never had to go to battle
buddy parade down the street.
And the fucking sense
observation because it's probably true,
but it would be just probably copied off of,
uh,
off of,
of a real one.
But,
uh,
there are places you can get things like that.
Uh,
you see it all wouldn't,
you know,
odd piece of that in the quarter.
Some,
some,
uh,
you know,
a home and garden place or whatever.
And you know,
I guess that's where they come from,
you know,
but I saw you guys at Jones beach in like a 2006.
You have awesome,
awesome show as always.
And I'm Motley Crue was opening for you guys growing their tour and they're,
uh,
recently they're there.
I think this is going to be there if their final tour and all of that.
Do you remember the,
um,
because I'm a huge,
you know,
being a drama Geek,
I'm a huge fan of Tommy Lee.
He was just like,
you know,
just the,
the,
the show that that guy puts on while also playing a beat.
It's just amazing.
I've always loved them.
And now I was wanting,
do you remember the first time you guys,
uh,
did you talk with them during their,
their,
when they were just young guys coming up?
Actually
I saw the,
what are their first gigs at the Santa Monica Civic Center when I was with the
project.
I was out here doing some gigs in and uh,
just for the fans.
Was this the first time Steven left during that period?
Was this like early cause of it?
No,
no,
this was stirred.
This was when I left in 1979 and I had the,
I was out here with the project,
uh,
at,
at some point,
I'm not exactly sure when,
uh,
but the bottom line is,
is I got to see them play,
you know,
at,
uh,
at the,
Santa Monica Civic Center,
which I don't know,
three,
5,000 seats.
And the buzz was out out of,
so the place was pretty packed in.
Got You there.
You just,
you just heard a good buzz of autumn.
You're like,
I'm going to go check these guys out.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
they said,
well,
somebody said these,
these are the,
the,
this is the new hot band on,
on the Strip and should check them out.
So I went down and,
uh,
I'm not sure if I,
if I've met him then,
but there were,
uh,
we had a couple of friends in common and I remember meeting,
Nikki Sixx and,
uh,
and just kind of like,
you know,
being kind of friends with them,
from kind of watching their career.
And then,
then,
uh,
we were in Vancouver doing,
I think it was,
uh,
the second record,
not,
uh,
not prudent vacation,
but I think it was the next one,
uh,
pump,
I think.
And,
uh,
and there are two studios in that,
in that place,
a little mountain up there in Vancouver,
and they were in the other studio.
And so we read it to each other a lot.
Oh,
wow.
So they probably doing that,
Dr feelgood right around that.
If that was 89,
nine,
that's right.
There were,
uh,
was,
let's see,
uh,
Mr Rock,
the,
uh,
the producer,
so,
uh,
producer the record I think,
and,
uh,
Bobby Rock,
right?
Uh,
yeah,
that's it.
And he was,
and they were,
they were,
they sounded great.
And,
uh,
they,
it was,
you know,
we rented to them pretty much daily and they,
uh,
and of course,
some of the guys,
you know,
would,
uh,
they would tag,
you have to,
after the session,
they would tag along and go down to the,
to the clubs.
You know,
Vancouver reputably is probably has the best,
uh,
from what I've heard has some of the best stories.
Right,
right.
You're like,
yeah,
I'm the headline.
I'll give you youngsters a ride down there.
They do everybody by the first day,
by the time,
is that hard to be around guys like that?
Because I know by then you'd,
you'd long since cleaned up and everything.
You had your fun basically at that point?
Not at all.
I mean,
it was not a,
not an issue.
I mean,
there were,
uh,
they were,
and they,
you know what they,
uh,
you know,
they would party like late at night after they were done,
but when they,
when they came into the studio with the afternoon,
they were all business,
you know,
meth as far as people like
did with a bottle of Jack Daniels and something.
Yeah.
Who,
let's go,
it's like,
you know,
they had work to do with,
uh,
you know,
it shows because it was a great record.
Hey,
did you ever call anybody out for doing the ice tea in the,
in the,
uh,
in the Jack Daniels bottle?
You know the couple,
I've heard a couple bands,
they would put ice tea in the Jack Daniels bottle and then they'd go out in
front of the crowd and act like they were crazy and they'd just be chucking ice
tea.
I heard about that,
but I've never,
he never busted anybody doing that
red and teddy buddy that did it.
But I heard stories about bids to win that.
But uh,
uh,
you know,
they don't rate very high on my respect.
That'd be like a prop act with the comedian and drink it.
You might as well drink it.
You know what I need and what's the,
what's the problem if you don't,
well,
I don't care how the big giveaways,
I don't give,
I don't care how much you've drank.
Nobody can chug hard alcohol.
You just can't do it.
You can fit.
Like I,
I've seen guys take big Gulps,
but once you start throwing the thing back,
like Joe Green in that famous commercial,
when he's drinking coca cola and even he had a couple of times on a couple of
takes,
the stop and Belcher,
whatever.
There's no way you could do with hard alcohol.
But before,
before we go any further,
I wanted to ask you,
you got a really cool tattoo on your forearm there of a second old school gun.
What's,
what's a story behind that?
Smith and Wesson,
uh,
break top fueled,
I guess it was designed back in the 18 hundreds.
Oh yeah.
Uh,
I just liked the shape of it.
It's one of my favorite,
favorite design.
It's an old revolver and a,
you know,
this is a place in New Orleans.
I didn't had an acting gig down there and uh,
somewhere in the French quarter they had all these old guns and rifles.
You ever been in that spot?
Drunk way too,
which muddy the place.
I wanted to buy my dad this,
this,
it was a rifle from like the,
from 18,
12.
Right.
It was insane.
And they even had the ban that and everything and my dad likes that type of
shit.
But the thing was for me to get it from Louisiana all the way up,
like first of all,
I couldn't get it shipped because Massachusetts has some sort of laws.
So then I'd have to,
would have had to buy it and then drive it up there.
And as,
as I was crossing state borders,
I just kept thinking about Tommy Chong when he sent the bongs out and shit.
And all of a sudden he had the feds at his door and you know,
who the fuck is going to drive from New Orleans,
Ella to Massachusetts and drive 55.
It's not going to be me.
I'm going to drive 80 at some point and be like,
I'm fine.
It's,
it's tough.
I think that they must get hanging out the back,
you know,
again,
without getting into the politics of things.
I mean,
uh,
I just think that the,
the things should be a little more,
things should be a little more standardized as far as firearms go.
I think they should be,
uh,
I mean people should be given at least,
you know,
put through more schooling before they're given a permit.
And it should be more standardized from state to state because there are some
states where it's,
it's easier to get firearms and there are other states where it's really hard.
It's hard to keep track of it,
you know what I mean?
It's insane how in some states you can basically just go in and buy it and not
have to prove any sort of capability.
I mean,
it'd be like given like somebody doesn't know how to drive keys to a car,
it's like they're going to kill somebody.
Um,
but I,
I honestly,
I don't have a problem with guns.
I think they are cool as long as the right person owns it,
which is the bigger course fly in the ointment.
But,
uh,
what are some of your,
you,
you like the gun,
you just mentioned there.
What is some of your,
uh,
you go to guns like right in some of the modern stuff?
What do you like?
Well,
I'm not really,
uh,
I mean I have a few modern it,
modern
firearms.
I collect all kinds of weapons.
I even got,
uh,
an old Greek sword.
Uh,
that's,
uh,
being out of broads.
It's all like,
it's green and it's,
it's actually quite small.
So I'll see.
You guys are very small,
you know,
I mean,
there were people were smaller than,
you know.
And,
uh,
so everything is like,
seems a little smaller.
But anyway,
uh,
if somebody broke into your house,
you can't tell me if that coming up the stairs.
Right.
And the only weapon you see is that old Greek Sword Party's got to be like,
God,
that cost me a fortune.
Well,
what they really want to run this guy through with it
within are going to be,
is focusing
on that while I walk up behind them with my shotgun.
Are you,
you're a shotgun inside guy?
Well,
I do have,
uh,
you know,
I mean it,
the,
they're reliable.
They're,
uh,
but what about,
what about it?
Understand as you,
uh,
if you're in that situation,
there's a,
a level of panic that comes with it.
And I've never been in that situation fortunately.
And uh,
I hope it stays that way,
but,
uh,
you know,
I'm not,
I've never been to the area.
I've never been trained and uh,
you know,
uh,
so I kind of look at things like the easiest thing that would be to have around
for,
for if somebody's got that far,
you know,
would be something that would be very easy to use and shotgun comes into that
heading.
So,
uh,
but again it's like uh,
it's an efficiency thing.
I've always,
you know,
cause I've actually tore through the south that I always tell them they're out
of their minds to have a shotgun in the house.
I got to hope bit coming out on my next special about it where I was think all
you need is like a 22.
Um,
cause it's easy to,
my big thing is you can,
when you're in the dark,
if you shoot,
you can still hear it doesn't,
yeah,
you've already lost your sight.
It's not going to take away your hearing too.
And people always laugh at at 22,
but it's like,
dude,
if I had it loaded 22 and I pointed it at you,
you're diving,
you're running away.
And if I started shooting you with it,
you wouldn't be laughing going,
this is the 22,
I could shoot you with a BB gun.
You can be like,
I'm going to get the fuck outta here.
People,
people,
you know,
it also kind of hard to tell what it is you have in your head.
The whole thing is so much,
there's so much psychology that goes along with it and I've studied a lot of
that because,
uh,
again it off.
You've got to have,
it's a great responsibility to own firearms.
And I've done a lot of,
of,
uh,
of studying,
I've worked with people.
I haven't actually gone to any,
any of the,
uh,
the,
the places we can go to trade.
But I've talked to a lot of the,
of,
of instructors and so on.
And uh,
and uh,
from what I gathered,
he had goods are probably the least effective in even in the hands of,
of trained you married people,
people miss.
I think that a Hemingway said that of all of all the weapons out there,
the weapon that misses the most is a handgun because there's so much moving in.
So much going on in,
I would think,
just the sound alone.
I'm hearing a gun.
I'm not going to be sitting there.
I'm breaking in your house counting shots like they do in the movie and that'll
be at the bottom going,
Joe,
I know you're out of bullets.
Come out with the,
I mean,
I'm not going to find the second step.
We start shooting at me.
I'm thinking I'm going to go rob another house.
I would just think people would do that,
but,
well,
I don't know if you know what I did see you on that show was at son of a gun.
Yeah.
Sons are good sons of guns,
man.
That must've been fun itself for people don't know.
I don't even know if it's still on this so many frigging channels and shows
these guys just,
it was like a hot rod show,
except it was guns and these guys would just make these insane weapons.
Uh,
and then people got to come on the show,
you know,
they'd weld like [inaudible] to have like the top of a Prius or something like
that.
Right,
right.
What did,
uh,
what did you get to shoot on that?
Like some anti aircraft guns,
couple of a of a hot rotted,
so to speak.
Uh,
you know,
like [inaudible],
things like that.
So we shot those.
But the main thing was I had this,
uh,
this old kid that was,
actually from the 18 hundreds,
and uh,
I really didn't know much about it and they could have cleaned it up a little
bit,
Eh,
cut into the serial number.
And it was actually a military issue that it was actually a naval gun.
And when two ships are at sea and they want to transport like cargo or a person
or something back and forth,
they need to send the line from one ship to the other.
So they used this kid and which is only about three feet long,
and they shoot this,
this,
uh,
this led dart over to the other boat and it,
it takes a rope with it.
Then they put the,
attach a bigger rope to it and then a bigger rope and a bigger open.
They'd finally,
they have this pulley thing so they can transport stuff back and forth.
So that's what,
that's what it was.
How many people who think accidentally got killed on the other ship?
You know when the him,
even though that they knew that they were shooting it over,
it was just such,
not an exact science.
He didn't really take wind,
you know,
you kind of wet your finger back then.
Right.
The people would probably keep their heads up watching with legal was going
sure that you got to a baseball game.
Somebody gets dinged in their head all the time.
They just fucking sitting there and these guys are like trying to hit 190 a
hundred mile an hour pitchers and there's always somebody just sitting there
eating and talking and they get,
they always get hit in the chest.
Thank God.
Like a few people have actually gotten hit in the head.
But I've got to ask you,
there's something about candidates that I realized as I was talking to you,
my only knowledge of Canon's is what I've seen in cartoons.
I'm not even trying to be funny here.
And there's this,
they tried to make it look like,
you know,
the thing that they stick in there is like a little bomb and then they shoot it
and explodes.
But it's really just,
it's just a giant,
like a ball made out of metal.
And that gets launched through gunpowder.
Right?
So this is giant metal ball wall,
sit pokes a hole in your ship and syncs it
or for what I had to see it cause I've read quite a few,
uh,
a historic novels and that part,
that part of history,
uh,
fascinates me.
You know,
the,
the tall ships and all that.
And apparently some of the,
some of the things that would put in there would actually be filled with
gunpowder with,
with a few.
So when it would,
when it would get shot off,
it would,
you know,
it was very inaccurate and,
uh,
you know,
was a wild work,
but it would,
it would,
uh,
you know,
it would lead of the ship hopefully explode,
but whatever
it goes back to the dark,
I'm saying it's very inaccurate.
They'd shoot it.
Yeah.
And they'd probably,
somebody caught it in the leg,
right.
And then they got a sawed off.
They just give them some whiskey up.
Right.
Uh,
tell you,
uh,
medicine was not anything near what we think,
you know,
think of medicine or w you know,
up till up to the end of the day of the 18th century.
It was like,
just basically that,
you know,
if you got a hangnail foot comes in because it's covered off or,
it was really bad.
Thank [inaudible] to stitch you up.
They just stick your leg in a fire.
Yeah.
Quick,
easy,
cheap.
You know,
so amazing.
Like the amount of pain that you can actually take.
You know,
I saw this,
this thing as far as like horrific ways,
horrific ways to die.
They had this thing.
Okay.
You did something and they decided that you are going to die and they had this
giant,
like it was like a fucking brass cow or some sort of animal it made out of some
sort of metal.
Right,
right.
And they would stick you in the fucking thing.
How they ever got you when,
cause I would've just killed myself.
They stick in the fucking thing.
They close it up and then they light a fire underneath it and they would just
basically cook you.
I've always thought about that laying in there as it's getting hot,
bouncing all around like someone who fucking fell off a motorcycle trying not
to,
you have the heat on you for too long.
Right.
It's just the,
the,
the fucking agony and how these people could just sit there and uh,
who's that?
Who's that guy used to?
Uh,
dates they put you on a,
what the fuck do they call the impaler?
Oh Yeah,
Vlad the Dracula,
they called it.
I love how you said that.
Like he knew him.
Oh,
I read a read,
read that stuff.
You know,
we've all read it.
We see it in movies.
You know,
he's a,
I actually watched the dealer,
you know,
he,
to me,
what amazes me is the way that people have invented to fuck other people up over
the years.
It just blows my mind.
I was the worst one you ever heard.
Oh God.
Well that was pretty close.
It would be that,
that really like that.
And I can't imagine being a,
I mean I love horses,
but I can't imagine being tied to four of them.
Ah,
you know what I mean?
And then having somebody yell go,
okay,
pull a little harder.
Not,
not even like,
you know,
get,
get up and go and like make it as short but like actually just kind of like,
oh they went holy walk slowly.
I mean that kind of thing.
That's,
that sounds like a pretty rotten way to go.
Those people listening at home or
basically they would tie,
you know,
your risks to one horse,
your rest to another,
your ankle to one,
you know,
and they would walk in four different directions and then he'd slowly fucking
dislocate your joints and then eventually just,
yeah,
pull you apart.
And that's,
yeah,
I would just want to say one thing I do want to say going back to,
we were talking about before which was uh,
about,
you know,
home in home defense and all that,
but one of the things that I've learned from talking to umpteen people about
this and that is that a dog,
any size dog is probably the most effective thing you could have in your house
for safety.
Just because the main thing is,
is getting some enough time to either deal with it,
to deal with what you have to deal with.
Make,
make the,
the nine one one call,
you know,
jump out the window if that's what has to happen,
pull out whatever your,
the,
your last ditch a weapon of choices.
But the main thing is buying some time and a dog will basically send the guy off
to somebody else's house and me and then it's their problem.
I got home,
I got a dog.
My dog will do that.
Like every once in a while I'll be sleeping and I,
and I get so terrified I've just sleeping.
All of a sudden I just started going
and I sit there going like,
what?
And I said I'm such a coward and immediately like,
and then I'm thinking like I should have got a gun.
I should have bought a gun.
You know,
I wish I had a bat here or something.
Well that's a good thing.
Nice.
This cop told me in life is stupid cause you got to get in close to at least
have a bat.
Yeah,
that's the dog.
It again,
a dog,
small dog.
Any dogs that you know becomes part of the family.
He's going to protect the pack.
Eh,
he's got to let somebody know.
And uh,
that,
that really,
they,
they on all the lists I've ever received,
they've put there like in the top three things you could,
you could have,
it could be the best thing.
Anyway,
I just want to get a wind down here cause I gotta I gotta another freaking thing
I got to run to once again.
Sorry that I didn't have a extra my quarter professional man.
Hey,
I need,
you mentioned that you went over there twice because the other thing you've
first one you brought didn't fit my stupid mixer.
Yeah.
It actually,
it goes to it or to an old microphone that uh,
like an old,
an old sour that needs power.
So it had to two more extra pirogues if works
speed to kind of,
he as I showed up unprepared,
but I got it.
Let me ask you,
can I ask you some,
uh,
a music Geek questions here?
Sure.
Okay.
Uh,
all right.
The,
the best live band other than your own bed,
best live band you ever saw.
Well,
they have to say,
my theory is,
is that,
uh,
rock and roll show,
if we're talking about rock and roll,
rock and roll,
see interaction,
interaction between the feds and the band.
A lot of times you might be at a club and we not even be a big bed,
but they're,
they,
they've got good songs and that they're getting the audience off.
And the audience who's giving them love in that,
the badge is given it back.
It,
you get that feeling like,
wow,
this is magic it right.
Then they might be the best band,
you know,
uh,
that night did the best band in,
you know,
you,
you walk away and you feel great.
And it was like an incredible show.
So that's kind of like what we strive for as we try and do that.
Try and get that magic going and that that's the thing.
You can't,
you can line everything up,
make sure they get ties,
are in tune,
make sure everything was working.
But it's really about,
you know,
hooking up with the audience and,
and having that interaction and having that excitement.
And,
uh,
I have to say that,
that one of the shows,
uh,
the that I've seen recently was actually the stones and it sounds like,
you know,
yeah,
of course,
pick the stones.
But it was,
I've seen him on nights when they just weren't that good.
You know,
I've seen them when they were really good back back in the 60s.
And uh,
but this particular night we were on the road in Germany and they played a place
in Berlin and they sounded incredible and it was like,
it was one of those nights where they,
where everything just locked together and you could see,
you know,
50 years of experience,
you could hear everything.
It was a,
it was a perfect,
a perfect venue.
It only held about 5,000 people.
And I was blown away.
I mean,
I,
you know,
I mean,
I figured it would be like,
you know,
well,
it would be like,
wow,
they're really good for 70 now.
There were as good as any bed I'd ever seen and they were as good as any of the,
the great shows I saw in the,
and in the day.
And they will,
they,
they knocked me out,
man.
I have to say,
you know,
who are anybody,
any young players out there?
Uh,
it's crazy now trying to figure out who the guys are cause there's no
centralized area for music anymore.
But are there any young players out there that you watch him play and they
inspire you?
Like man I got to go home and practice or I want to,
I want to try to take my,
you know,
like just as a comedian to try to relate it.
Like you know,
I love new comics and I was seeing somebody,
there's nothing I love more than seeing a young comic that I know is going to be
great.
Right.
And um,
and you see and they got the hunger,
they got the drive,
they've got the talent and you know that they're going to,
you just know,
you know they're going to do it.
I always,
that always gives me like a jolt of energy cause I remember what that was like a
bee in their age and stuff and like how,
you know,
just sort of trying to recapture like,
cause sometimes you can get into the grind of it.
I was wondering if there was any like bands that are out right now that,
that make you like,
fuck man,
I,
you know,
maybe you're not near,
you could talk.
And he just like,
fuck,
I wish I had my guitar in my hand right now.
I want to just,
just start making music.
I don't really,
here's some good,
some good music.
I was in the studio the other day.
There was a bid that was being recording and you know,
the vocal was a yet,
but the music sounded like it had likes real potential.
Uh,
it's a really hard question because it's like,
there are a lot of technically oh,
great players and there's a few,
like really great players that are really young.
Uh,
they're,
they have,
uh,
there's so much on the Internet.
I mean you can,
I mean back when I was growing up,
I had to,
I had to struggle to find somebody who even played guitar much less,
uh,
you know,
get a,
get a lesson,
you know.
But,
but you know what,
I fucked up my foot trying to figure out John Bonham's bass drum technique
because I was trying to do,
it might like my big toe and I was like arch in my foot and I got like a,
what do you,
what do you call it,
that planter Fisher writers.
Really.
And now it's like you can go,
cause all I had was like a record player and speakers and you stick in your oh
it down.
And now like Nia,
you just go on Youtube and somebody just shows you.
Yeah.
And like a slight step,
you just kind of move your whole fort in it.
It's like,
you know,
you led goes up once but you get two hits and it's just,
and then I'm watching like some fucking kid,
like eight years old playing all that stuff and I'm just like,
it's,
they can get like a year's worth of drum lessons or guitar lessons in one night
on Youtube.
It's,
that's exactly it.
And you know,
I mean the,
it's all spelled out and that's why I think there are a lot of,
a lot of good guitar players out there that are technically good.
They can play the play,
all the stuff,
but still it still comes down to writing a good song,
writing something that,
that,
you know is a little bit original and you know,
and it is entertaining and it still comes down to that.
You can be a,
you could be a wizard on guitar,
but unless you're a guitar freak,
you know,
as far as like,
entertaining,
your average rock fin is still going to write,
write a good song gotta connect.
You know what I mean?
And it's had no matter,
you know,
whether it's like,
you got 6,000 computers and you got,
you know,
it's running through tape machines and all,
like he could all the best equipment unless you got a good song,
you still get nothing.
So that will ever change.
Let me ask you,
cause I gotta I gotta wrap up here.
As far as your book that's out,
uh,
first of all,
where,
where can fans get it?
I know it's on Amazon,
if any local bookstores.
Well,
there's a few actually is,
there's a lot more than I expected.
I went through probably six or seven cities and,
uh,
most of them we went to,
I think we,
we did a couple of Barnes and noble,
but we did mostly a more mom and pop kind of places.
But what I found out was most of them do their business online.
And so there's,
there's some competition for it was on,
you know,
it keeps everybody kind of honest.
There's a little bit,
he's got a monopoly,
you know,
so,
uh,
but uh,
basically the best thing to do is,
is uh,
either order from your local bookstore,
support,
the,
you know,
Marvin pop kind of places or you know,
get it from,
from a others right now,
hopefully it should still be on the shelves.
And uh,
I know I signed a bunch of them so this still has,
this is still an opportunity to get some that have been signed.
You know,
what
people buy the book.
Uh,
is there a favorite story or one that comes to mind if you've got a quick one
that you want to tell here at the end?
Uh,
is it basic?
Is it stories about you on the road with these guys?
Is it,
is it the whole thing like Joe,
it's an autobiography from the time I put both feet on the ground
from 64 years of life,
I've been a part of that.
Is there a Smith's,
you know,
yeah.
I've been a fan of you for so long that I know some of the store.
I remember we'd like you told some cool story in some other interview where you,
um,
how you ended up getting into guitar.
You were a young kid knows these older guys sitting on the front porch playing
guitar and you're like,
ah.
It just sounded really cool.
Just sort of captured your attention.
Um,
I,
well personally I cannot wait to read it and I'm like fascinated with that whole
period of music that you came up in.
And I also like that whole thing where you guys,
you know,
had to stick your ear to speak or try and slow it down.
And because I find a lot of times when I'm,
you know,
I messed around with the guitar too and I try to watch somebody play it,
then turn my back to the video cause right.
Cause then people like the person who will literally break it down,
show you that,
where they put their fingers and stuff and people will still ask for tabs.
And I'm just looking at it like,
don't you ever want to have the freedom to like basically be,
I've always figured becoming literate in music means you could listen to it and
figure it out.
Where if you always had to have tabs and everything was almost like you couldn't
even read.
You know what I mean?
Somebody had to hold your hand.
And uh,
like I think this a lot of people out there that can really play all this shit,
but if you just played it on a record,
can you sit down?
Maybe you don't need to do it anymore because there's someone who will,
will,
will break it down for you.
But,
uh,
but anyway,
soon,
I'm such a huge fan,
uh,
you and your band and all this stuff that you guys have done,
I never even thanked you for all the great music.
I mean,
it's basically a soundtrack of my youth.
Um,
they love all your stuff and I'm so psyched for this book.
I cannot wait to read it.
Uh,
once again,
it's called Joe Perry,
my life in and out of Aerosmith.
Uh,
so psyched.
I finally got you here on the podcast.
Good luck with the allergies.
Thanks for Sean.
Well,
you stories about guns and all this other stuff.
I hope a,
I asked you some different questions.
It did.
It was great.
And we'll have to do this again because I was,
like I said,
I was looking forward to it.
I've been looking forward to it before the book or,
you know,
I mean,
uh,
you know,
I mean it,
the main reason was because we're from Boston.
It's great to hear the accent and just can't get rid of it.
I ran it by the way.
Come to it again.
We'll talk about the civil war,
you know,
definitely.
Definitely.
All right.
Joe Perry,
his new book,
my life in and out of Aerosmith is available all over the Internet and,
a,
if you've got a mom and pop store down the street and you want to them out,
bookstore down there,
please go down and pick it up.
Uh,
Joe Perry,
thank you so much for listening to the Monday morning podcast.
Hope to see you soon.
Okay.
It's an honor,
so thank you.
All right,
brother.